-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with the cast
of "Squid Game" right there!
Welcome.
"Squid Game" is all about
playing childhood games,
so I thought we could have
some fun with that.
You're about to face off
against each other
in the "Tonight Show
Schoolyard Games."
Here we go.
-♪ Schoolyard Games, ooh, yeah ♪
-Now, the games will now begin.
All will play,
but only one can win.
Round one, Slapsies.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Applause ]
This is the game where you do
this over each other's hands.
You can kind of fake out,
but if you fake out
and you flinch and move all
the way back, you slap the hand.
But if you can do it
fast enough and just go like --
wa-psh!
That's Slapsies, yeah.
Yeah.
It might not be called that.
We might have made up
the name "Slapsies."
But that's the game.
Jung-jae, Hae-soo,
you're up first.
On your mark.
Get set.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Go.
♪♪
-Whoa!
-Wow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hae-soo, you won that one.
[ Laughs ]
Not at the whole game.
Okay.
Ha-Joon, Hoyeon, you're up next.
♪♪
-[ Speaking native language ]
-Okay.
I want to...
-Three, two, one.
♪♪
Yeah! Oh, my God! Yeah!
First try!
-[ Speaking native language ]
-All right. That means we go
to the final round right here.
Hae-soo, Hoyeon,
you are up against each other.
Yeah. Good --
Best of luck. Yeah.
This is what I'm talking about.
-All right. One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
-[ Laughs ]
Are you okay?
-Congratulations.
It is time for the next round.
And things aren't
going to get any easier.
Because you're about to play
one of the most dangerous games
of all --
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
Jung-jae, Hae-soo,
you are up first.
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
Whenever you're ready,
you can go.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-[ Bell dings ]
-Jung-jae!
Jung-jae is the winner
of that one.
Ha-Joon, Hoyeon, you're up now.
-Both:
Rock, paper, scissor!
-Okay.
-There's two scissors.
-Rock, paper, scissor!
-No!
-[ Bell dings ]
-Here we go!
Now, Jung-jae, Ha-Joon,
you guys have to go head-to-head
rock, paper, scissors
to see who the winner
of this match is.
Here we go.
I know. Look at this.
Whew. Gear up.
Mentally focus.
When you're ready. Yeah.
-[ Speaking native language ]
-[ Bell dings ]
-Oh, yes!
That's what I'm talking about
right there!
Ha-Joon! Congratulations, bud!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. We've now reached
the final round.
This determines
the winner of everything.
But before we play, each of you
must pick a number
between 1 and 4.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I will go...number two.
-Three.
-Okay.
-Four.
-One.
-Yeah, you have no choice.
You have no choice.
You're one. Okay, here we go.
Now that your numbers are
locked in, the game may begin.
It is time
for Egg and Spoon Race.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
But not all spoons
are created equal.
The number you choose
determines your spoon.
Please take the spoon
that matches your number.
-Ah.
-What is number two?
-Three.
-Number two!
Yeah! Number two!
-Yeah, that's a good one.
-[ Laughs ] Four. One.
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
One, you got --
You have a tough --
[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
Oh, no. Oh, no. Okay.
Oh, no. All right.
When you're ready, take your
places and get ready to race.
The first person
to cross the finish line
with an intact egg
is the winner.
On your mark. Get set.
-On my mark.
-Go!
-Aah!
-Ohh! Hey! All right.
Jung-jae. Jung-jae, you get it.
But you know what?
You're all winners.
I want to thank
the cast of "Squid Game."
The number-one show on Netflix.
Streaming right now.